[Music]
it's seven o'clock here in the uk you're
very welcome to spend your breakfast
with us here at sky news
there are two things on people's minds
this morning
questions over plans to relax
self-isolation rules for those who've
had
two coveted vaccines but not until later
this summer
that's amidst a warning of a potential
big rise in cases
on the show today the business secretary
and the shadow foreign secretary
plus can england keep the euro dream
alive when they meet denmark at wembley
tonight
we'll be talking to fans and the danish
boss of brentford
[Music]
fc
[Music]
uh well as england fans dare to dream
i'll be speaking to the wembley
dj who will be responsible for
celebrating
or maybe commiserating with england
supporters tonight we'll be asking him
exactly what is on his playlist
and from pop stars to presidents
we'll be chatting to the man who's met
some of the world's biggest celebrities
in his quest for autographs it is
wednesday
7th of july pressure on the prime
minister
amidst predictions of a big rise in
covert cases over the summer
and questions over self-isolation rules
being dropped for some
but not quite yet
fever pitch as england prepare for the
semi-final against
denmark their manager says it's going to
be a tight game
it's a challenge for us um if we were a
country that had won five titles and
you know we we had to match would have
gone before it might feel differently
but
we're not covid's
fake news we speak to doctors who say
there is no evidence
that fertility will be harmed by
vaccinations
i stand for my principles i think
i'm just doing my work gunned down
crime journalist seriously injured after
being shot in amsterdam
winter olympic boycott the calls for
action over the 2022 events
if that is the united nations is stopped
from investigating alleged human rights
abuses
of the uyghurs
good morning sunshine and showers again
today but i think we'll see more and
more sunshine
and less in the way of showers so fewer
showers and
not quite as heavy for many so a little
bit more promising perhaps i'll bring
you more details later on
[Music]
morning all there are two stories in
time today
you might just have heard there's a big
football match on tonight
and there are a lot of questions and
concerns
about the latest revelations on coveted
freedoms people who've had two
vaccinations will have to wait
until mid-august before the
self-isolation rule is dropped for those
who've come into close contact
with someone who's tested positive many
however are asking
why the weight all this amidst a warning
of a big rise in covert cases
with some predicting that millions could
catch covered this summer
the business secretary quasi quarting
will be with us in just
a couple of minutes uh but before all
that
millions are preparing to watch england
play denmark for a place
in the euros final manager gareth
southgate says the game
will be tight but that they're motivated
for the challenge
serie chowdhury as our first report
what a journey it's been for fans of
english football
it's england v denmark in the euro
semi-final tonight but who will clinch
the win to reach the final
i think it's got to be england it's the
first uh euro semi-final in 25 years
in front of a packed wembley ruled on by
60 000 fans
there's been plenty of discussion on
redemption for gareth southgate after
his penalty miss
saw england go out in the most dramatic
way at the same stage in 1996
but for many the england boss is beyond
that
he's just the second manager to take
charge of england in a semi-final at
both the euros
and the world cup the only other manager
to do that was sir alf ramsay
in 1966 and 1968.
tonight's hopes rest on these men raheem
sterling has been england's standout
player at the tournament
while harry kane is back among the goals
at the right time
it's a motivating thing it's a challenge
for us
um if we were a country that had won
five titles and
you know we we had to match what had
gone before it might feel differently
but
we're not despite
soaring covered rates in england wembley
stadium has an increased capacity of 60
000 fans for tonight's game
and they're predicting big numbers of
their own
english video mark three one scorers
hurry kane sterling declan rice gecko
rice we're standing
on muscat two two one england two one
two one
[Music]
the stakes are high for alan hansen no
not that one this one is the sales
director at this danish meat factory in
manchester
where he's massively outnumbered by his
english staff
we got the upper hand albeit it's on
wembley
i think england will be on a tremendous
pressure
playing in front of a 60 000 crowd
[Music]
they may be singing about going to
wembley here at this danish school in
london but they'll have to stay up way
past bedtime
to see who gets to return on sunday with
seven consecutive clean sheets
it's england who are the favorites
a win tonight and they'll face italy
they beat spain in a penalty shootout in
wembley last night
kickoff tonight is at eight until then
time
will surely pass slowly sadia chowdhury
sky news
uh well as you can see the business
secretary quasi quartet joins us in the
studio great to see you this morning and
of course we will be dwelling on england
in just a moment
and of course the latest revelations on
covet but
but you're making a fairly significant
announcement i have to say today uh in
terms of life sciences tell us about it
absolutely right um life sciences have
been really at the forefront of
our fight uh against kovid and people
know
around the world that the uk is really a
leader a world
leader in the life sciences and today
we're launching
uh the life sciences vision which is
essentially a strategic look
at how we can maximize uh great
potential
and our ability in this really crucial
area it's all about
uh being able to get proper medicine
have high level research
and critically commercializing that
research making great businesses
out of uh really strong fundamental
science
well like any any progress that can be
made particularly on cancer dementia
anything like that learning the
successes from covet 19 i think people
will
absolutely but at the same time we are
now in a situation where
we were listening to the health
secretary yesterday we could be seeing
cases
new daily cases in excess of a hundred
thousand
over the summer i just want to dig down
just a little bit deeper into
into what that might actually mean if
we're talking about cases of a hundred
thousand a day
perhaps by the time we reach august by
by the 16th of august when
when the rules change on self-isolation
you could have over
a million and a half people
self-isolating because
they have had they had a positive test
you could have probably double that
people that they've come into contact
with even people who've been double
vaccinated
who would also be off work can we just
have someone from the government concede
there will be millions of people who
will be isolating this summer as a
result of the unlocking
i don't think you can necessarily
conclude that there'll be millions
we've always said uh significantly we've
always said that significant numbers the
numbers would be going up but of course
the critical thing neil is
what the hospitalization rates and uh
the fatalities as well and the numbers
we've seen on that
have been much much lower than anyone
anticipated
and that's becau because of the success
of the vaccination program
and i think that's what's giving people
protection we've always said
we've always believed that infection
rates might go up
but the critical point is what their the
effect of those
infection rates is and i think the
vaccination double doses particularly
give a measure of protection that we're
that we're happy with
it will clearly all however have an
effect on business which we'll talk
about in just a second
but in addition long covert is is
clearly a thing
and if we're talking about a hundred
thousand new cases a day
i mean estimates vary but a ballpark
figure of 5 000 people a day
acquiring long covered or in at some
point in the future achieving
acquiring long covered symptoms i mean
that's that's not beyond the imagination
is it
it's not beyond the imagination but i
think we've got to get uh i think you're
getting ahead of
where we are because uh what i speak to
what i
like what i hear is that we can't simply
uh lock down the society forever
we have to reopen if we don't reopen
fully on the 19th of july
the implications of that would be simply
just to delay all of this
uh till perhaps september and and in the
winter
where things would become more difficult
so it's a balancing act we have to
decide
uh what to do and i think this is the
best uh course of action i mean viewers
will see that i have my i've had a
vaccine badge on this morning my second
jack was yesterday which is it explains
in part why i'm a little bit grumpier
this morning
than usual but why if we're going to
open up the country
in july why are people like me going to
have to wait until
august to avoid self-isolating if i come
into contact like this
at this distance from someone who's
covered 19 positive yeah i mean again
there's always a balance so people on
the one hand are saying
that uh the 19th of july is too soon for
general reopening and other people are
saying
uh that it's not soon enough in the case
of self-isolation we feel that he does
uh delaying it for four weeks does give
a measure of protection it allows more
and more people to be jabbed
and we think that that's uh that's a
precaution that's worth
uh worth taking but we're opening up
hospitality
people will be in pubs bars restaurants
potentially without wearing their masks
we understand of course that the
hospitality sector 16 to 34 year olds
make up 60
of the workforce and none of that well
very few of them
will be double vaccinated even by the
middle of august
do you accept the fact that the
hospitality industry is going to be hit
incredibly hard if hundreds of thousands
even millions of people
are going to be self-isolated as a
result of us opening up perhaps
in the view of some just a little bit
too early i think we're making all sorts
of assumptions here what we've got
um we've got to make something is
the worst possible case my own view
about the hospitality sector is that
they
were very very keen to reopen if you
speak to pub owners if you speak to
people
in the hospitality business they were
very disappointed that we didn't
open up on the 21st of june and i think
many of them
uh the majority would say that this is
the actual the right precaution to be
to be taking them very happy i think
they were all very happy because they
assumed that come july the 19th people
who were double vaccinated would be able
to avoid
self-isolating i mean obviously you're
the business sector you know a fair
amount about business but
you know julian metcalf you know the
founder of itsu the founder of press and
monge
i mean he's described this strategy and
i quote as completely and utterly mental
well you can't have it both ways on the
one hand we're saying that we want to
reopen but we're
giving a measure of precaution in terms
of delaying um the
the self up lifting the self-isolation
restrictions it's a balance
it's not it's not a perfect solution but
on the one hand we're saying
that we can reopen and on the other hand
we're saying that we want to give a
little bit more
protection in terms of the
self-isolation rules sure but it's not
even just people in business that are
saying this in the head of the
hospitality uk has made similar comments
to mr metcalf i mean ian duncan smith
makes the point look
why go into a pub where people are not
still adhering to the rule of sex
you know where there's no social
distancing because in all likelihood
if you go to the pub more than a couple
of times a week you will get pinged
at some point and you will have to
isolate so the big thing here
is that we need to rely on people's
judgment uh there's a
common sense and a degree of individual
responsibility
that's always going to be ultimately
what we have to rely on and in this
instance
we've said we're going to reopen uh
people will be allowed
not to wear masks to do what they they
choose
but also the businesses themselves will
be conducting
a business in a responsible way i think
this is perfectly reasonable
just in terms of of who might well be
affected i mean we understand of course
the younger you are the less likely it
is that you've had a vaccine certainly
to
be double vaccinated isn't it the case i
mean you you don't accept the figure of
several million people uh isolating
others have suggested it
it's fairly standard but that means the
infection will be running through
young people won't it once again the
youngest in our society those that have
lost frankly from certain perspectives
the most in all of this will once again
have to
have to suffer tell me that this isn't
you know heard immunity by another name
so
again as i always say there's a balance
when the uh this awful illness struck
uh it was very apparent that uh certain
groups were much more vulnerable than
others
in the case of covid it was uh older
people that's why
the vaccination rollout happened the way
it did we we targeted older more
vulnerable
people and the view the medical view was
that younger people
had more protection than more vulnerable
groups
uh clearly we're looking at uh
vaccinating younger people we're looking
at what jcvi are going to say
um but we feel that on balance
the best approach is to try and get our
kids back into school and get them back
uh into normal life where do you
personally sit on the idea of
vaccinating you know
12 years and above well i don't know
what the medical uh opinion is i would
definitely defer to the jcvi on that and
they're going to
make their their ruling or their their
judgment uh public very soon
do you not though have any concerns no
one in government around the cabinet
table expressing concern you know you
think back to kind of
you know late last year cases were
nowhere near 100 000 a day
but infection was running rampant in
parts of the country in
kent for example and a variant of
concern emerged i mean if we're talking
about
running higher than at the highest point
you're in the january peak
in terms of cases there is a real risk
isn't there
that we're just you know playing a
waiting game until another domestically
produced
perhaps even more resistant to vaccine
at variant emergencies
so again there's as i always say there's
a balance but the critical difference
between
this time and late last year has of
course been the vaccine rollout we've
had 75 million doses
we've had two-thirds of the population
uh certainly getting the first dose
and that's a completely different
scenario than was the case last year
just to just sit with businesses and of
course plenty of people
been challenging the government on the
the removal of the mandatory requirement
the mandatory wearing of masks where do
you sit in that i mean what in what
circumstances will you be winning a
matter so i've always said that
uh i believe in individual
responsibility i think businesses
uh have a uh their own discretion
they're in judgment
i think uh individuals should also use
their own judgment
um personally i would i use the tube a
lot in london
and i would probably use them wear a
mask in that context
in the tube in public transport that's a
personal view
it's not something that i would mandate
or necessarily dictate to other people
but you'd be quite happy for
businesses say airlines hospitality
sector
to require to continue to require people
wearing a mask inside their premises yes
i mean
actually before covid it was very
interesting that businesses always had
um have always had the ability to to
prescribe
um certain um health or they've always
had that
and i think we're going back to the to
that situation people have forgotten
that actually businesses did have some
discretion in terms of what people
um the thing that people have always
struggled with this is that the weighing
of mass yeah there's a degree to which
it's a prophylactic measure that you're
looking after yourself but it is in
essence about looking after others
i mean if you are someone who say has
leukemia you're immunosuppressed you're
sitting on public transport
do you think that they have a right to
demand that other people wear masks
so if we wind the clock back to
pre-covid we have people who are
immunosuppressed we have flu
and what would happen in those days was
that the they would take the advice from
their doctors they'd take medical advice
and i think i'd expect that to continue
uh postcovid
one quick question just before you go of
course the football on tonight's
we i i will be not necessarily
supporting with full
voice but i'll certainly be cheating a
little bit from the sidelines how do you
think it's going to go
i think england will win um we haven't
conceded a goal yet
i think it's a pretty remarkable
scotland i don't want to jinx i don't
want to jinx anything
um you know government ministers
predicting uh football
games probably isn't the best thing for
us to do but i think i think on form if
you look at the what's happened
i think england have got a really good
chance and i hope i hope they can
they can actually convert their
brilliant performances into victory
tonight
we will soon find out we'll may air
quite a question thank you this morning
thanks very much
still to come on the show this morning
appropriately enough
at willow the cockapoo has correctly
predicted
england's results at euro 2020 as
well as other major events we'll hear
what she's forecasting for tonight's
match at 10 to 8 to see whether or not
the minister got it right
tony perry is the wembley dj who will
either commiserate
or celebrate with england fans tonight
he'll be running us through
his playlist at quarter tonight
and we'll get a diplomatic prediction of
the score from tonight's semi-final
at 9 20 when we're joined by the
danish ambassador to the uk lars season
but now one of holland's most respected
crime journalists is fighting for
his life after he was shot in the middle
of amsterdam
our reporter aisha zahid is at the
newsroom for us aisha tell us more
what a brutal attack police say that
they've made
several arrests three people rested in
total
two found in a car and one arrested in
the city
the city after the attack took place and
peter r devries was left
seriously wounded the attack took place
near a large public area in central
amsterdam
it happened just after he left a tv
studio where he was filming a regular
guest appearance now the 64 year old
crime journalist
is a prominent figure in the netherlands
he's known for his investigative work
and his tv shows as well as his
extensive reporting
on the criminal underworld in the
netherlands it's something
he has in the past received threats for
and needed police protection for as well
uh and it was long feared he'd become
victim to one of the criminals that he
had reported on so police will be
continuing their investigations to
determine what happened yesterday and
who is responsible
and they've confirmed that peter r de
freeze remains in hospital fighting for
his life
chet thank you uh well let's take a look
at the
latest coronavirus figures for the uk
now there were
28 773 new covert cases 37 more deaths
were reported
that's the highest number since the end
of march now that means the total number
of people who've died within 28 days of
a positive test
now stands at 128 358.
the latest vaccination figures show
another 76
962 people received their first jab 147
814 had their second so that means in
total
33.8 million people have now received
both doses of a covet vaccine
however there are fears that some false
claims linking fertility issues to
covered vaccinations online
could be putting women off having them
that's guys kate mccann has the detail
while science has moved fast in the
pandemic so has misinformation and the
vaccine has often been the target
experts warn fears about fertility are
causing women to refuse the jab
news that over 13 000 have reported
changes to their period since being
vaccinated
have fueled those concerns for these
vaccines we have quite a lot of evidence
that they
don't reduce your chances of getting
pregnant so in the clinical trials
um people were asked not to become
pregnant but nonetheless
65 people became pregnant by accident
and they became pregnant equally in the
vaccinated and the unvaccinated group
which tells us that the vaccine isn't
reducing people's chances of getting
pregnant
what would you say to a woman you know
maybe thinking about having a family
wants to get pregnant hasn't had the
vaccine yet
and is really worried about hearing
these reports about people's periods
changing worried about fertility
what would you say to her today we know
that sex hormones affect the immune
system and the immune system affect
sex hormones and actually one quite good
example of this is that we have some
evidence that the flu vaccine given at a
certain time in your cycle
can slightly dampen the amount of
progesterone you have
and it's the balance between estrogen
and progesterone that builds up and
breaks down the lining of your uterus
so if these get slightly out of whack
then we might expect to get a heavier
period
or a later period when you look at some
of these facebook groups it gets really
dark really quickly in fact not getting
the vaccine when pregnant or trying for
a baby could
doctors warn do more harm so there's no
evidence that the vaccine affects
long-term fertility
um could the vaccine if the vaccine
makes periods irregular for a month or
two
could it make it a bit more difficult to
fall pregnant in that month or two well
theoretically possible
maybe you wouldn't obviously release an
egg in that month but
is that a reason not to have the vaccine
i don't think so because bear in mind
that
if you're pregnant and you get coveted
infection it tends to be a bit worse
on average for both mother and baby
anything that stops people from coming
forward to vaccination centers like this
one to get their jab is a problem for
all of us because the government is
relying on
high levels of immunity across the
country to move away from restrictions
and into normal life again and to do
that they need to get people to feel
happy and safe
to come forward to get their job vaccine
hesitancy is right at the top of the
government's agenda as ministers prepare
to unlock society they're relying on it
to protect normal life
but it can only work once it's in our
arms
kate mccann sky news
some of the other news uh this morning a
coronavirus
lockdown and australia's biggest city is
to be extended for another week
restrictions will remain across sydney
because of the number of cases of the
delta variant
the government claims that thousands of
potential new coronavirus infections
have been prevented after a mass testing
program in liverpool
the scheme which ran between november
and april so more than half the city's
population take a test
senior republican party officials say no
data was lost
during a major ransomware attack the
white house says it was one of the
largest
international hacks ever attempted with
17 countries affected
one of india's best-known actors dilip
kumar has died at the age of 98.
he'd been acting since the 1940s and was
known as the tragedy king
for playing numerous serious roles the
indian prime minister narendra modi
described him
as a cinematic legend
as a story brown trout can become
addicted to meth amphetamine
according to scientists a team at the
czech university of life sciences say
the fish are
affected as illegal drugs make their way
from domestic
water supplies into rivers
more on that as we get it now there's a
call for britain to prepare for a
boycott
of the 2022 beijing winter olympics if
that is china blocks a u.n investigation
into alleged abuses of uyghur people
let's speak now to our asia
correspondent tom cheshire
morning tom i mean you've done an awful
lot of work on this over the past couple
of years and it's pretty clear
the chinese state has something of an
unhealthy relationship with its weaker
population
yeah i mean there are allegations we've
been to xinjiang on numerous occasions
to look into these allegations there is
potential evidence for what
the us and the uk say are massive human
rights abuses and that is of course
something that
china denies and as a result of that has
been growing pressure to boycott the
olympics going to be held here in
beijing early next year
while china is carrying out these
policies and today the labour party are
saying that actually no british
royals or ministers or officials should
go to the olympics while those abuses
are happening while china is not
allowing that investigation they say
if an investigation isn't allowed before
september
that this should be the case they're not
saying athletes shouldn't go by the way
they're just saying
that officials shouldn't go so the
question is is china going to have an
investigation you might remember the
last time
china allowed an investigation was the
world health organization coming here to
look into the origins of covert 19
and their report was roundly discredited
including by the health
of the world the head of the world
health organization so that idea of
getting access to
xinjiang to looking at the detention
facilities there
huge sprawling detention facilities and
seeing what's happening inside is pretty
unlikely before the end of the year
the question of course is what reaction
the chinese will have to this statement
they don't like it when people as they
say
interfere in their own internal affairs
we've seen in the u.s nancy pelosi the
uh speaker of the house has led similar
calls she was called
despicable by the chinese foreign
ministry so i think we can anticipate a
similar
sort of reaction from beijing today to
this proposal from the labour party
tom many thanks uh time for us to check
in and see how the
weather is looking today as we head
towards the semi-final another
interested party kirsty is at the wall
with the details
go on kirsten tell me is the sun going
to be shining on england at wembley
tonight
um well it will for a time yes there's
some showers around though this evening
but the showers will fade so by the end
of the match it should be a little bit
drier but then also given its evening
getting darker too
let's take a look at the weather shall
we
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
good morning for many of us the weather
is a little bit quieter over the next
few days we've got more in the way of
sunshine
less in the way of showers but we do
still have some showers around so fewer
showers
not quite as heavy but still some to
watch out for rather gray start in the
south we'll see the cloud breaking as
the day goes on
further north across scotland though
that cloud may prove a little bit more
stubborn
now the showers today will be hit and
miss not as many as recent days but
central and eastern areas could still
pick up some heavy ones especially parts
of eastern england eastern scotland
could still see a rumble of thunder
maybe even some hail and gusty winds
in the sunshine though we're looking at
temperatures into the high teens low
20s 22 not out of the question and the
showers that do develop today will tend
to fade away
as we go into the evening now across the
far north of scotland does stay rather
gray here and we've got more clouds
spilling in across parts of northern
ireland republic but otherwise
a fairly dry night with clear spells and
temperatures sting in double digits
the outlook for thursday well fewer
showers yet again
bit more cloud out to the north and west
but there will be some brighter spells
and it should be largely dry
greatest chance of seeing some showers
will be across southern and eastern
parts of england and maybe the old
sharp shower a bit warmer though
temperatures up to 23 celsius
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
castle thanks very much senior members
of the royal family
have been getting involved in the euro
[Music]
[Applause]
2020
you recognise that well at the uh
request of the prince of wales the band
of the coldstream guards played eight
series of football anthems that covered
restrictions mean that crowds weren't
able to gather
so instead the guards played three lines
and sweet canline
in the gardens of clan's house for the
duke and duchess of
[Music]
cornwall
[Music]
which version do you prefer there um
just a couple of the england fans that
are preparing for tonight's match
our supporters are expected to buy get
this
more than 50 000 pints a minute
during tonight's semi-final and the
british beer and pub association
estimates that just under 7 million
drinks
will be ordered throughout the game one
hoax
because you're celebrating and not
drowning your sorrows
still to come we'll be talking to the
association of school and college
leaders they claim the government
is trying to blame teachers for the
large number of pupils being sent home
to isolate
that's coming up after this
[Music]
what this is and study shows is that you
know not only
is um a four day working week with no
reduction in pay good for workers in
terms of better mental health better
well-being
it's also good for the employer for
greater productivity which we'd already
started to see with increasing amount of
companies
now trialing a four-day week across the
world from unilever in new zealand
microsoft and japan and this was one of
the biggest studies of its kind
uh which has led to now 86 percent of
iceland's population reducing their
working hours
and it shows that it can be done the
nine to five five day working week we do
not need to
keep with that anymore that is a very
outdated model of work from the 1930s
where um it's been implemented and
trialled
lots of researchers have been doing the
analysis as they go interviewing staff
along the way
to see how they're managing to cope with
their their you know
their workload over say a six month
trial and nine times out of ten
productivity is going up all staying the
same and that's not surprising
you know if we're burnt out overworked
and stressed we're not going to do a
very good job
whereas if we have a bit more time for
ourselves to rest then we're going to
come back in on a monday morning much
more motivated to perform better in our
jobs
this is a policy that is you know good
for the environment good for workers and
good for the economy
polling shows the majority of people
would like to have fridays off which is
no surprise you know
the idea of a free weekend is very very
popular three day weekend
um but in in all we wouldn't be able to
do that in all cases so yes for for a
lot of firms we would just be able to
shut the office on a friday for example
and everyone just has an extra day off
but we need flexibility built into the
implementation of a four-day week and so
there'll be various different ways of
doing it some firms for example a big
social media organization in the us
most of their staff have friday on
fridays off but they have a
customer-facing team
who take a different day off each week
and swap it around so there's different
ways of implementing it and where
flexibility is built into the system
it seems to work best
we are at a breaking point and we need
to work
now and fast even though young people
are vulnerable to the import of climate
change
young people can also become the change
agents that we need to address
the climate impact in my campaign or in
advocacy work i work entirely with young
people
so that their voices can be heard so
they can also influence
decision making from the local level to
the national level and thankfully
we are making progress in a regard
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back you can't have it both ways
that's the warning from the government
this morning
as they face criticism for changing the
rules on self-isolation for adults
it will now be august the 16th before
fully vaccinated people in england will
avoid self-isolation
if they come into close contact with
someone testing positive for covet 19.
but businesses say it will hold back the
recovery a point i put to the business
secretary just a short time ago
you know julian metcalf you know the
founder of itsu the founder of president
monge
i mean he's described this strategy and
i quote as completely and utterly mental
well you can't have it both ways on the
one hand we're saying that we want to
reopen but we're giving a measure of
precaution in terms of delaying
um the the self-lifting the
self-isolation restrictions it's a
balance
it's not it's not a perfect solution but
on the one hand we're saying
that we can reopen and on the other hand
we're saying that we want to give a
little bit more
protection in terms of the
self-isolation rules in this instance
we've said we're going to reopen people
will be allowed
not to wear masks to do what they they
choose
but also the businesses themselves will
be conducting uh business in a
responsible way
i think this is perfectly reasonable
our political correspondent tamara cohen
is here with the review and all of that
and i suspect there'll be plenty of
people tc who have a view on whether or
not the business secretary might be i
don't know slightly more sympathetic
towards business
yes the business secretary was very
unapologetic about the fact that the
date that
people who've had two jabs will no
longer have to self-isolate the whole
system
of being pinged and having to stay at
home for 10 days that date was a lot
later
than people expected because you've got
the easing of restrictions on the 19th
of july
and that doesn't end for another four
weeks now he told you
we couldn't necessarily say it would be
millions of people self-isolating by
then during of course the holiday or
perhaps staycation
season but if according to an analysis
today
for every person who's off another two
are self-isolating
if we get to a hundred thousand cases as
the government say we might well do
then that does quickly run into the
millions and the governments seem to
want to say
look this is what we have to do if we
want to open up now
these are the consequences but for a lot
of people that's going to be a bit of a
miserable summer
certainly will be tc thanks very much
indeed now
a town in county durham will be
celebrating its
unique position in tonight's euro 2020
semi-final
both goalkeepers england's jordan
pickford and denmark's casper schmeichel
have both played for darlington fc
currently
in the national league guess where we're
heading our correspondent fraser mod
is joining us from darlington this
morning ah where i suspect things are
already at fever pitch
not quite just yet but they will be in
the next hour or so when the children
start arriving here at
mountain junior school we're about three
or four miles away
from darlington fc's ground where as you
say caspar schmeichel
and jordan pickford both made their
professional debuts casper schmeichel
back in 2006 out on loan
uh from manchester city jordan pickford
in uh 2012 out on loan from his club
uh sunderland obviously they both went
on to great careers both domestically
and internationally and uh there'll be a
lot of people rooting for hopefully
jordan pickford more than
casper schmeichel this evening i can
have a quick chat with the head teacher
here pete king what are the children
like how excited are they getting about
about the match tonight really excited
i've been in quite a few classes this
week the the older children
uh are very aware of it as you'd imagine
i spent some time in one of the younger
classes some 60 year olds year one
a couple of days ago and you'd be amazed
how many knew the result from the
weekend the scorers
that kind of thing it's a shame we can't
meet in the hall and have whole school
assemblies but the awareness is
definitely there
yeah the exam is building for today for
sure so they're getting excited for
later on yes oh yeah yeah and we've got
some children coming in a bit then
you know you guys are here it's all
adding to it so yeah very excited
fantastic well we'll be back with a few
of the children later on this morning to
see just how excited they are but in the
meantime
i'm back to you from here in darlington
the home of the international goalkeeper
thanks very much indeed and as fraser
says we will be back
in darla a little later on at when the
kids pitch up at primary
now teaching unions have welcomed the
government's plans to ease the system of
bubbles which has forced
thousands of children to isolate and
miss classes but they're worried about
what the government's plans are when
schools return from
the summer holidays uh joining us now
the general secretary of the association
of school and college leaders
uh jeff barton jeff good to see you
again um
i i wonder what your reaction is of
course to the uh to the relaxation on
the bubble rule
you know a little bit too late i would
suspect
well it's difficult to know i think neil
i mean you look at that school in
darlington and you've got those young
people
not able to have a school assembly
alongside 60 000 fans going to watch the
football last night i mean
with 640 000 young people off school
last
last week i mean that's the government's
figures not because they've got covered
some might have but because they might
have come into contact
the bubble system simply isn't
sustainable so we welcome
the fact that that's been dismantled
it's important to say it's not being
dismantled
yet and parents will have to kind of
stick with it through till july the 19th
but at least the end is nine with all of
that which then leads us to think
so what might september look like and
that's where we've probably got more
questions as you imply
yeah well well tell me what are those
questions about september i mean clearly
the one thing that you want to try and
ensure is that pupils maximize their
time
in a classroom with a teacher with a
teaching assistant getting face-to-face
learning
that's exactly right so one of the
things that the government told us
yesterday is that they want to have
that regime of testing at the beginning
of term in secondary so in other words
young people will not be able to set
foot into the classroom
until they've done a lateral flow test
that immediately means that what you're
going to have at the beginning of
september
is a staggered return to young people
because each of them has to do the test
has to wait half an hour for the result
etc so we're not immediately going to be
back into the normality of school life
and i think quite a lot of people given
what we've been through so far where
there's been
face covering social distancing bubbles
staggered start staggered lunch times
extra ventilation which bits of that do
we definitely need to keep for example
the whole face coverings thing i
personally
loathe them but a lot of people
recognize that they are one way that you
demonstrate how you're looking after
other people and the thing
neil which is distinctive about a school
of course is if you're an adult working
in a school whether you're the secretary
whether you're a teacher
you are surrounded by large groups of
people
who will not have been vaccinated in
september the adults will have been
but young people won't and i think those
measures which just build reassurance
both for the staff in the school for the
young people in the school
but also for the parents sending their
children back to school
would just give an extra sense of
reassurance that it isn't all or nothing
which i think today for some of us
it feels a bit too much like yeah and of
course it's not just mass the
the requirement to keep socially
distance has dropped as well i mean
what what is your view obviously you you
speak on behalf of your members but you
don't speak on
behalf of individual schools i mean what
what is your view do you think that
there will be
educational establishments up and down
the country who choose simply to
to maintain the rules as they were
before they were dropped
i think the majority are going to try to
default back to the kind of normality
uh that we used to have so that the art
block is used for art
rather than putting all of year eight
there without them being able to move
across the school
that's been one of the patterns of
secondary schools so i think there will
be a sense of trying to get back to
normalizing i think we might see some
schools holding on to some of the things
we've learned
through the pandemic for example i think
we might still have staggered lunchtimes
not because it's a health risk but
actually it's created a calmer
environment and
shorter cues i think we might see
parents evenings being done differently
in the future i think
there will be some things which have
changed but i think the most important
first step will be the reassurance to
parents
both of what their responsibility is in
the testing the fact that
test and trace the nhs program costing
37 billion is finally going to take
responsibility for
public health in schools and colleges
that's a good thing but also the
reassurance about whether extra
ventilation
and some other measures might be needed
in order that we
educationists can focus on the most
important thing education
do you have any confidence that by the
end of term that will be the end of the
the major disruption that pupils will
face in their education
well by the end of this term i mean if
if we continue at the rates that we're
going at the moment 640 000 young people
not in school and
almost half as many again also not in
school this is the big untold story i
think
not because they've been told to self
isolate they've simply disappeared it's
almost as if
parents are voting with their feet if
you look at the beaches of cornwall that
might give us
some indication of where those young
people are at the moment so there's
something about this term i think we
just have to grit our teeth and get
through as best we can
i think all of our priorities now need
to go to into making
as normal as possible school and college
life for all those young people who as
we're seeing today
on average have lost a third of a year
of their teaching
over the past year yeah and it's not as
if their school years aren't stressful
enough to start with uh jeff barton
great to see you this morning thanks for
being with us thank you
well as the vaccine program reaches the
final people to get their first jabs the
government is
still considering plans to make jags
mandatory excuse me
for some health and social care workers
a number of companies in britain in the
united states say
they're also considering the idea for
their employees
uh well we can talk now to melinda mills
professor of demography who sits on the
sage group for behavioural insights
uh professor great to see you this
morning thanks very much for being with
us um
well let's just start with that shall we
what
is you what is your view in terms of
vaccination in terms of
the way in which people will behave as
we move forward i mean
just a general question has the vaccine
uptake been where you want it to be
yeah so if we look at it um you know
within the uk
there's actually been a very high uptake
we have a large proportion of the
population being vaccinated
but we still need to get groups out so
people to get their second jabs
and also it's uneven across different
areas across the uk
but also across different
socio-demographic groups and it's really
related to a few things so i think
people are increasingly confident about
the safety those concerns were large at
the beginning
but i think a lot of people can now see
this these are these are very safe
um and as well i think the big problem
now um
our biggest uh fear will be complacency
that people will think oh do i really
need to get it um
and also the other one is convenience of
course too
so it has to be available for people to
get it and um
you know there's been various incentives
around the world that have been
introduced
to try to try to not make it mandatory
but to give
people incentives so things such as in
the u.s
oh go ahead no no no please please
please finish please finish
yeah so incentives such as uh in the us
for example
i mean they've offered things um from
lotteries to university scholarships for
for for children from from 12 to 17.
they've offered beers guns uh
my favorite child care um you know to to
try to
incite people and say you know could you
would you please get
uh vaccinated in california the first
two million people
um were given gift cards for example so
there's lots of different kinds of
levers and incentives you can offer
people rather than
making them mandatory yeah i have to i
have to hope that they weren't handing
out the beers and the guns at the same
time in america um but just in terms of
that which you said a moment ago i'm no
behavioral scientist you're the person
with the insight into all of this but
with the announcement of the relaxation
uh on july the 19th many of the
restrictions going
can can we just automatically assume
that that will have a negative impact on
vaccine uptake no i don't think we can
can immediately think oh people will be
less likely to to
be vaccinated i think it could even have
the opposite effect
that people will be more will be
thinking okay i'm more likely to be
exposed
i think the real issue we'll have here
is inequality and who has
been able to be vaccinated so as things
open up we have restaurants we have
sporting events all of these different
things
the staff that often works in these
places are young
and they'll have the opportunity only to
have the first
vaccination and the second one will come
you know as late as september
so they won't be fully protected and
they'll actually be quite exposed
and then we'll come into questions which
you were talking about in relation they
could be asking their employees you know
isn't sure isn't it your duty of care to
protect me
so some people particularly younger ones
that haven't had the opportunity to be
fully vaccinated
during this in-between period could
really have some concerns about their
own protection
they certainly could um professor mills
i'm afraid we're going to have to leave
it there but it's good to see you this
morning thanks very much for being with
us
thank you now new york
city has seen unusually unsummer-like
weather thunderstorms and heavy winds
caused well as you can see
plenty of damage across the city
overnight debris
spotted hundreds of feet flying in the
air flying past
the city's high-rise buildings
now a heatwave in pakistan means that
the country is seeing some of the
highest temperatures ever seen the city
of jacobabad saw some of the most
extreme conditions
with temperatures of 52 degrees celsius
that's
126 degrees fahrenheit
uh the chief meteorologist at r d
islamabad
syed mushtaq ali shah joins us now from
pakistan outside great to have you on
the program this morning and
i i do hope you're keeping cool
temperatures
of 52 degrees celsius have you ever seen
anything like it
few years uh this summer uh it was from
june 7 to 9. and especially it was more
intense in this
north and northwestern parts of pakistan
their temperature
was more than around six to eight degree
more than normal deception and we have
many
events during these periods for the
disastrous event
in which one was in northern pakistan
where there was a glacier search and
due to this search a new lake has formed
which is
very much dangerous for the people
living below this area
and we are continuous monitoring this
bishop sir and other impacts were some
uh these fruit origins
it was very
unfortunate that foods are approved
orchards of oranges and
apples and some more foods completely
dried away
during this period and
[Music]
other impacts were very low because
pakistan with logical departments have
had a warning a timely warning to the
communities of these area
so at least we are fortunate that
there was no capabilities
during this period i'm
to interrupt sorry to interrupt but just
tell us how how are
people managing to survive in
temperatures as high as
as 52 degrees celsius presumably people
just simply aren't leaving the house
actually this is not new for pakistan
and if you um
continue to monitor it you will see that
uh every year
we face these
two or three pays every year especially
in
may and a month of may and june so
the maximum people of these areas are
born timely and they make their own
arrangements for their
safety and to
avoid such incidents so that's why in
pakistan
human loss during these heatwaves is
very less
um alisha we're going to have to leave
it there but thank you very much and do
stay as cool as you can and look after
yourself in those temperatures thanks
for joining us
thank you thank you very much
appropriately enough time for the
weather
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
good morning temperatures here are
around about average
at the moment so low 20s really is where
we're peaking in the summer sunshine and
there will be a bit more sunshine to
come
over the next few days there are still
showers around but not as many as we've
seen
so the showers today mainly in the south
where it's a bit cloudy to start the day
and also across parts of northern and
eastern scotland
most of the cloud breaking up through
the day but i think the far north has
gotten staying rather gray
the shower is greatest across central
and eastern parts of britain so
a few thundery downpours to watch out
for and temperatures into the low 20s
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
let's head back to the euro shall we and
to predict the score of tonight's
england denmark match some fans well
studied both sides form analyzing
thousands of statistics on this program
however we prefer something rather
different
willow the cocker poo has so far
correctly predicted
all but one of england's matches in the
tournament and i'm very pleased to say
joining us now on the show at the mystic
cockapoo willow
and our owner charlotte price uh
charlotte um
good just good to see you this morning
um we will talk about the results in
in just a second but when did you first
recognize
that you possessed a psychic puppy
you know it was definitely i think a
little by accident
and willow's always kind of been able to
choose between two things
and so if you hold two things up in
front of her she will choose them
and it turns out um she can choose the
winner
um so yeah just a little bit by accident
and but so far she's doing quite well
with it
yeah i i mean i'm not one for for
gambling on the football but i've
occasionally put a couple of bets on
political
events and i'm i'm told that willow has
actually correctly
correctly called presidential elections
in the past
so yeah we held up a picture just with
the word trump on
a picture and just with the word fired
on and said who are you back in willow
and her paw straight for the the correct
one
well i i have to then ask the the big
question
of the day um england denmark
okay what's what's the what's the result
going to be
go and tell us so we don't have a number
on the score line but death
uh will i definitely chose england for
the win
and do you know was she barking
furiously was it just a little growl was
i mean i just want to know how much
money i should be sticking on this
tonight as a result of your cockapoo
i'm not suggesting anyone goes on sticks
or more because she's on with those
predictions
however and like we said she's on a roll
she was pretty confident and she's woke
up this morning with a spring in a step
um so yeah i'd feel pretty confident if
you popped a little bit of money on
but she doesn't she doesn't say very
much i have to say it's one of the
calmest dogs we've ever had on this
particular program i mean is there
is there anything that she might be able
to take these skills
to use in the future you know we're talk
we talked about political betting or
anything like that
i mean she could work with scientists on
climate change maybe some kind of
research anything like that that you
think might be useful
i mean anything is possible isn't it and
she has been helping me do a little bit
of online teaching through the pandemic
so she can spell her name do her numbers
do her shapes
um so yeah never say never and she
definitely
is a bit of a wonder pooch um
i i've gotta ask obviously i can see
this in george's flag behind you the
three lions on her underbelly i think
it's probably the way to put
it uh does she support any other teams i
mean do you think you might be able to
get her in her scotland shirt anytime
[Music]
i think she definitely goes with her
little patriotic hat when she's making
these predictions
so i'm not sure of scotland sure
um but you never know yeah my my psychic
highland terrier proved
absolutely useless during the euro 2020
campaign for scotland this year
and just a final word though charlotte
how are you how will you guys be
watching
um so we'll be watching at home tonight
we've watched a couple in the pub a
couple at home
and but with being near willow's bedtime
we're going to watch at home tonight
well look i will keep fingers crossed
that the pup has the result right
charlotte
willow thank you both very much for
being with us and good luck tonight
thank you for having us take care